el viaje hacia el norte ha terminado el
frente de la comisión de ayuda a
refugiados de mexico ante las
dificultades de cruzar la frontera hacia
estados unidos cientos de migrantes
haitianos están pidiendo asilo en la
nación azteca
esa persona que está
en la ciudad fronteriza del río en eeuu
están varados unos 14.000 migrantes
muchos de ellos haitianos
1400 han sido deportados de vuelta a
puerto principe su tratamiento suscitó
indignación incluida la del alto
diplomático estadounidense en haití que
renunció quien denunció un trato
inhumano el trato que muchos haitianos
de vuelta méxico experimentaron al otro
lado de la frontera si me siento que
nosotros estamos allá
y eso que queríamos porque
lo que más allá son son muy malos para
nosotros imagínate cruzamos allá ellos
si fuera que nosotras somos basura desde
el terremoto de 2010 miles de haitianos
han salido a vivir en países
latinoamericanos como brasil o chile una
nueva ola de emigrantes huye de la
pobreza una violencia de las pandillas
mientras esperan por un futuro mejor
descansan por el momento de su larga
travesía